[Musique]
son travail révolutionnaire jfk fête ses 30
ans cette année
et stone revient sur le sujet
avec un documentaire de
suivi jfk revisité à travers le miroir
actuellement en première au festival de cannes
et oliver stone, lauréat de l'académie,
me rejoint maintenant depuis
le festival merci  tellement oliver pour
euh
venir évidemment nous avons un
président américain à la maison blanche qui soutient euh
euh les forces contre le gouvernement cubain
plus
changer euh avant de passer aux
preuves
euh qui euh que nous n'aurions pas
sans
jfk le film euh dans  votre nouveau documentaire
quelle est la pertinence au cas où les gens
vont oh il ne parle plus de kennedy
la pertinence pour joe biden qui
bombardait la syrie et l'irak seulement ces dernières
semaines quelle est la pertinence pour la
maison blanche actuelle de ce documentaire
bien je pense  la pertinence est que le
point principal que nous essayions de faire valoir
dans le documentaire était que john kennedy
était un guerrier pour la paix
sous toutes ses formes et parmi les nombreuses choses
il faisait quand il a été tué
tendait la main à cuba pour mettre fin à cet
embargo pour faire une
raillerie avec castro ça avait l'air bien et il
était aussi en même temps
sur la conclusion d'un accord global avec
khrouchtchev de l'union soviétique
qu'ils avaient ils ont signé le nucléaire  tester
ensemble le traité d'interdiction
qui est un document étonnant la première
fois que les soviétiques aux États-Unis
signaient un traité de cette nature et la
guerre froide
prenait théoriquement fin en
1963, vous pouvez donc imaginer où le monde
serait maintenant à la place nous avons  cette
politique rétrograde où les
États-Unis ont toujours un embargo sur Cuba
60 ans plus tard et les nouvelles d'aujourd'hui ne sont
qu'une autre dans les longs
événements de crise simultanés qui se produisent
toutes les quelques années, je ne sais pas que cela
dure depuis
des décennies, c'est  une honte et les
preuves dans
le nouveau film rappelons simplement à notre
public comment vous avez fini par témoigner au
congrès
et pour ce qu'on a appelé en fait euh
l'une des
lois les plus strictes sur le gouvernement ouvert jamais
pa  ssed par le congrès jfk records act a été
adopté à la suite
du euh le film qui a créé un pour
une fureur un congr i justifié au congrès
et ils
ont adopté la loi et cela leur a permis
de
déclassifier des documents et de faire une
enquête limitée cela a duré quatre  années
de 94 à 98 et a découvert un travail assez
substantiel
mais malheureusement les médias américains ne l'ont
pas signalé
au public il a été enterré oublié
dans le trou de mémoire qui est devenu l'affaire jfk
donc en 2013
j'étais assez frustré quand tous les
réseaux  aux états-unis
célébrant le 60e anniversaire de
l'assassinat de kennedy,
aucun d'eux n'a mentionné euh les
théories alternatives ou mon film en
gros j'ai été interviewé pendant près d'
une heure et demie par
tom brokaw de nbc et ils l'ont réduit
à un clip de 20 30 secondes
les médias n'ont pas été
équilibrés, ils se réfèrent toujours à la
commission Warren comme s'il s'agissait d'
une sorte de document précis alors
qu'il y a eu trois officiels
dans  vestigations
résultant de ce meurtre, nous essayons
de dire d'accord, soyons honnêtes,
voici ce que nous avons trouvé et nous mettons
toutes ces informations dans la
plupart de ces informations dans un film de deux
heures.
Je suis très fier de ce documentaire et
c'est vraiment  soulève de nombreuses questions la
présidence des états-unis
depuis john kennedy il était le dernier
président à vraiment travailler pour la paix
dans le monde il cherchait comme je l'ai
dit ce détont
et il se retirait entre
autres du vietnam
cela a été contesté à la sortie du
film  en 91
et maintenant nous avons plus de preuves à partir
des dossiers déclassifiés
que cela se produisait définitivement parce que
robert mcnamara a écrit un livre
en 95 robert mcnamara était son
secrétaire à la défense et
il a dit que sans aucun doute avec kennedy
avec le retrait et
même si nous devions perdre cette guerre  nous
retirerions
que les vietnamiens nous allons
gérer cette guerre à partir de maintenant
après que mcgeorge bundy qui était
conseiller à la sécurité nationale pour
kennedy soit sorti  avec son livre et a dit
la même chose bien que
bundy était contre le retrait, il l'a
définitivement dit
aussi nous avons un appel téléphonique de
lyndon johnson
qui sort mcnamara et dit que vous savez que
je n'ai jamais voulu me retirer comme vous les gars
je n'ai jamais été d'accord avec vous et  kennedy
quand vous avez dit que nous avons cet appel téléphonique sur
bande,
donc cette preuve est insoluble que les
historiens américains l'ont nié,
vous savez vraiment le nier,
c'est dommage que cela changera, les jeunes
historiens
viendront parce que ceux de gauche
autour du  le monde pensera à kennedy
et ira bien il suffit de regarder le dossier il a
augmenté le nombre de conseillers au
vietnam
il euh n'a pas signé la loi sur les droits civiques
il euh il a été l'instigateur de euh
macho euh bordel avec euh khrouchtchev
sur la crise des missiles cubains
qui d'un autre côté vous pourriez dire que lui
et khrouchtchev sont venus
sauver le monde parce que que son
stylo le pentagone
les généraux poussaient kennedy à aller
à cuba pour envahir
à  déposer une arme nucléaire sur cuba il y a eu beaucoup
de pression sur kennedy pendant des années
pendant trois ans kennedy a pris 11 ou 12
décisions de
ne pas envoyer de troupes de combat il a envoyé des
conseillers parce
que cela a été fait à cause de l'implication de l'administration eisenhower
dans la guerre du vietnam et avec  les français
se souviennent qu'il y a toute une histoire ici.
en algerie
il n'est pas descendu ici il a fait un discours
sur l'algerie condamnant les
armees francaises dans
leur guerre en algerie le colonialisme n'a
pas marche pour lui
rappelez vous il etait irlandais il n'etait pas anglais
euh et euh
il avait une attitude une rebellion contre
le  monde colonial
il ne voulait pas que cela continue il
avait d'excellentes relations avec l'afrique
l'affaire lumumba l'a vraiment détruit
je veux dire il était bouleversé au-delà de toute croyance au
meurtre de lumumba la
cia était impliquée  y travaillait pour la
paix à tous les niveaux en
indonésie il avait une excellente relation
avec le vietnam pour lui
était une erreur et il devait se
retirer tranquillement il devait le faire
il ne pouvait pas le mettre au vote parce
qu'il allait se présenter pour  un vote en
novembre 64 qui est dans quelques mois,
il
a délibérément signé un
ordre de retirer les mille premiers
soldats avant noël 63. que deux jours
après sa mort a été
contredit par johnson lyndon johnson
donc tout historien qui dit qu'il y en avait
continuité entre lyndon johnson et
john kennedy
c'est de la foutaise bien sûr le
chef a été assassiné euh
par euh des forces soutenues par les états-unis réprimant
des moments terribles euh terribles pour le congo qu'est
-ce que les preuves suggèrent alors
sur l'implication de lyndon johnson
et gerald ford dans la dissimulation  encore
moins
euh alan dulles de la cia euh qui
euh a été limogé par la dissimulation john kelly
c'est une honte que tout d'abord que
lyndon johnson ait nommé alan dulles
qui a été viré par  kennedy en tant que chef de
la cia
kennedy jurant de briser la cia en
mille morceaux
dulles a été mis au conseil d'administration avec la
commission warren à sept personnes et en
contrôlait une grande partie contrôlait
toutes les informations provenant de la cia
au conseil
en s'assurant que  rien de désobligeant ou
quoi que ce soit à propos d'assassinats à l'étranger
n'a été mentionné à ces autres
commissaires, ce
qui fait une grande différence
en plus de cela, lyndon johnson doit être
considéré
comme faisant partie d'une dissimulation qui ne veut pas dire
qu'il était impliqué dans l'assassinat
parce que nous ne pouvons pas prouver cela,
mais Lyndon Johnson était sur le point d'être renvoyé en
tant que vice-président
que nous savons et
il voulait que cette chose disparaisse, il
ne l'a pas fait, il a dit que nous ne voulons pas d'une guerre
avec la Russie, nous ne voulons pas  accuser la
russie c'était une sorte d'excuse pour
nommer et nommer la commission warren
ils voulaient une transition pacifique c'est
ce qu'ils c'était un mythe
que johnson prendrait le relais et
continuerait la politique de kennedy  au fait,
vous avez mentionné les droits civiques, mais nous
en parlons dans une petite section où
kennedy
est félicité par martin luther king pour
ses avancées
sur le front des droits civiques en faisant entrer ces
étudiants noirs dans des collèges
du sud,
ce qui est tout un exploit avec george
wallace en alabama
wallace était un ennemi de kennedy et a
juré qu'il le
ferait tomber qu'il le
ferait, il affecterait le vote en 64.
kennedy a fait beaucoup plus que ce qui est
reconnu et c'est faux
c'est vraiment mal qu'il  est euh
considéré comme président macho macho uniquement
parce qu'il est plus jeune
je vous rappelle qu'il était un vétéran de la
seconde guerre mondiale et
décoré et savait qu'il ne faisait pas confiance à ses
généraux c'est vrai
après euh la catastrophe de la baie des cochons où
alan lui a menti  dulles
il a dit à plusieurs membres de son
entourage
que les généraux en étaient pleins
et qu'il
ne fait jamais confiance aux généraux parce qu'ils vont
vous faire entrer dans une guerre il y aura un tas
de défilés
un  Et puis bien sûr, vous êtes coincé avec l'
attrition de la guerre et les dégâts qu'elle cause
, il avait donc de nombreux ennemis sur le pentagone
et de nombreux ennemis dans la
cia, il y avait des gens au sein de sa propre
administration qui étaient,
je dirais, prêts à le trahir
et  la preuve
la preuve suggère que l'
assassinat était à double usage
je veux dire qu'ils auraient pu l'empoisonner
s'ils voulaient euh
arrêter jack kennedy introduisant une pax
americana
euh dans la maison blanche c'était pour
faire croire que c'était un assassin pro-cubain
et donc devrait permettre euh l'
implication
euh contre fidel castro ce n'est pas le
moyen le plus simple d'assassiner quelqu'un
si tu veux le blâmer seul non
ce serait l'endroit pour le faire le
faire dans une foule c'est pourquoi je dirais que
c'est aussi
dans sa seconde  -tenté de remettre un avertissement
un avertissement à d'autres personnes, y compris
lyndon johnson, de ne pas franchir une certaine
ligne
lorsque vous faites exploser la tête d'un président
au milieu d'un casier de cortège qui
est une opération
noire très organisée donc  il y a beaucoup à
faire juste la sécurité le long de l'itinéraire a
été changée l'itinéraire du défilé a été
changé tous les mécanismes de ce jour
ont été contrôlés et faisaient partie d'une
opération
et quand cela s'est produit, je pense que c'était
très clair pour le peuple américain
inconsciemment peut-être  qu'il y avait des
forces plus grandes que n'importe quel homme
qui nous disaient
que ce que c'était un c'est un changement
un changement dans notre système dans un sens
le sens de la démocratie s'est éteint parce
qu'après ce
kennedy aucun président américain pas un
et vous pouvez y aller  en bas de la liste a pu
apporter des changements à l'intérieur de ceux-ci le
secteur militaire de l'économie
ou le secteur du renseignement
les ces deux les agences du gouvernement
étaient intouchables leurs budgets n'ont
jamais été réduits
bien que kennedy ait essayé de réduire le
budget de la cia a essayé de le briser
en  un millier de pièces ses directives
ont été annulées par lyndon johnson
tout ce que kennedy a fait sauf les droits civils a
été annulé par johnson,
y compris l'aide pour son pr  ogresse pour l'
alliance lance pour le progrès en amérique du sud,
y compris ses initiatives africaines,
y compris ses initiatives indonésiennes
johnson demi-tour à 180 degrés une autre chose dans laquelle nous entrons
est lee harvey oswald nous nous avions accès
maintenant déclassifié
nous avons des informations dont la cia était tout
à fait consciente  il
savait où il le supervisait de
1958 à 63,
ce qui fait de lui un atout de la cia,
c'est incroyable
et nous savons aussi que jack ruby était ac
était un informateur du fbi,
donc nous, les agences de renseignement, sommes
impliqués avec ces personnes
du début jusqu'au  fin euh aussi
donc on sait qu'oswald c'est crucial
n'était pas au sixième étage
quand les coups de feu ont été tirés car personne ne l'a
vu les
trois personnes dans les euh trois femmes qui
travaillaient au quatrième étage
elles ont témoigné deux d'entre elles ont témoigné et
leur témoignage était  changé par la
commission warren
et nous les avons retrouvés un autre
chercheur l'a retrouvé dans les années 1990
et a compris et la nouvelle est que
ces trois  Les femmes ont descendu les escaliers
tout de suite
ne m'ont pas vu Harvey Oswald dans les
escaliers et
ils ont témoigné et signé tout cela,
mais cela n'a jamais été écouté par la
commission des mandats,
ce genre de changement des
déclarations des témoins est très important pour cette
affaire,
Oliver a  pour vous arrêter là une
seconde nous en saurons plus d'oliver stone
après cette courte pause
oliver vers la fin du
documentaire,
vous avez sans doute le fils de robert kennedy disant
que
la première réaction de ce robert kennedy à la
nouvelle de l'assassinat de jfk a
été de téléphoner à la cia et plus ou moins nous l'
avons-ils fait qui a dirigé cette horreur
était sa citation réelle à
venir  robert kennedy jr très jeune
il a dit que pour nous il nous raconte l'histoire
robert kennedy a soupçonné quelque chose le premier
jour
et jackie kennedy et lui ont écrit une note
peu de temps après
t  o khrouchtchev en union soviétique
me disant
qu'ils savaient que ce n'était pas un complot russe
pour euh tuer kennedy qu'en fait
c'était un
groupe de droite aux états-unis ils ont dit dans
la lettre qui avait fait ça
il y avait une correspondance entre le
kennedys
et khrouchtchev qui se déroulaient
avant l'assassinat,
c'est un angle de signe euh intéressant,
mais il est très
clair
pour robert kennedy que son père en 68 se présentait à la
présidence
sur une partie de cet ordre du jour était qu'il
allait revisiter
il était  va promulguer les politiques qui
avaient commencé sous
John son frère et qu'il allait entre
autres
se pencher à nouveau sur l'
assassinat parce qu'il n'a
jamais cru à la commission Warren
entre autres choses,
il savait que quelque chose se passait et puis pour
cette raison je fais  croire que robert
kennedy a été tué de sang-froid
et rapidement parce qu'ils savaient ce qui était
en jeu
s'il entrait en fonction il y aurait l'
enfer à payer
parce que le soi-disant secteur  les médias de tream
qui nous ont menti à propos de l'irak
nous ont sans doute menti à propos de la syrie ils sont
très rapides à
dire et font écho à james woolsey euh plus tôt
cette année qui bien sûr a dit bien sûr
que c'était un
plan soviétique qui a mal tourné pour tuer jfk
ils ont dit qu'ils ont dit robert  kennedy était
le procureur général
de johnson si si robert kennedy était si
convaincu de cela, il aurait pu
poursuivre
les personnes impliquées dans les
vraies personnes impliquées dans l'assassinat de jfk
je vous ai dit qu'il y avait un appel téléphonique sur lequel
nous l'avons  nous avons les voix sur
bande où lyndon johnson dit clairement à
robert mcnamara
que c'était une mauvaise idée de se retirer du
vietnam je veux dire à
quel point pouvez-vous être plus clair que johnson
n'était pas d'accord avec les politiques de kennedy
et euh il avait l'habitude d'utiliser
l'assassinat assez rapidement pour prendre
contrôle et dans les deux jours
ish a publié le mémorandum d'action de sécurité nationale
qui a annulé ce qui a essentiellement mis en place un
nouveau
militantisme dans la position américaine au
vietnam  g nous pour mener
des patrouilles aériennes et des patrouilles navales le long de la
côte nord vietnamienne
puis s'est terminée par la
débâcle de la baie de tonkin en août 64. le faux drapeau
car il fait maintenant de plus en plus cool
et c'était la base de la guerre mais
pourquoi robert kennedy ne l'a-t-il pas fait
pourquoi n'a-t-il pas démissionné en tant que procureur
général,
son patron a été coupé le premier jour, je veux dire
au moment où
vous voyez que vous devez comprendre que
robert kennedy était en conflit
avec le juge aspirateur le fbi qui est l'une de
ses
principales agences principales, aucun robert kennedy
n'était  n'avait aucun pouvoir après la
mort de son frère parce que johnson a
pris le relais
et j edgar hoover avait raison
respirait le trône de robert kennedy
et d'ailleurs l'organisation du fbi hoover
était le principal contributeur d'informations
à la commission warren, ils leur
fournissaient des informations
et nous maintenant  Sachez d'après les
déclassifications dans le film que nous
montrons
que parmi les choses qui ne se sont jamais
présentées à la commission Warren, il y
avait un rapport Seibert O'Neill Wh  ich deux
meilleurs agents du fbi
étaient là à l'autopsie à bethesda
et ont témoigné très clairement qu'il y avait
une blessure à la tête massive à l'arrière de
la tête de kennedy
qui n'a jamais été vue sur les
photographies issues des
photographies officielles issues de
l'autopsie qui  indique
une divergence par rapport à ce que les gens ont vu de
leurs propres yeux
il manque encore des papiers
ils étaient censés être
libérés évidemment nous sommes reconnaissants à
donald trump d'avoir libéré
certains d'entre eux pensez-vous que joe biden
va les
libérer il a jusqu'à  le 26 octobre, euh,
pour prendre une décision
sur la libération des autres, l'atout a
dit bien qu'en raison de l'
application des lois sur la sécurité nationale et des préoccupations en matière d'affaires étrangères,
je n'ai pas le choix de permettre d'
accepter les
expurgations plutôt que de permettre
un préjudice irréversible à notre
sécurité nationale par des documents relatifs à  l'
assassinat de kennedy
donald trump a reculé il a dit qu'il
allait tout lâcher et il
ne l'a pas fait au dernier moment il basi  l'a
poussé à la présidence de Biden
par l'administration de l'information,
c'est maintenant qu'il nous retient illégalement et illégalement
ces documents,
à nous et aux gens, donc
que nous les verrons ou non, nous ne
savons pas que nous allons essayer, il y a un procès à
venir  contre l'
administration biden de la part des citoyens à nouveau
pour la publication de ces documents qui
nous sont dus c'est ridicule après 60
ans d'appeler et de
parler de sécurité nationale dans cette
affaire
ouais ça contredit le euh jfk records
act de 92 que vous
qui êtes sorti du  à l'arrière de votre film, de
toute évidence, les attaques médiatiques ont déjà
commencé contre le documentaire même
s'il n'a été présenté que
cette semaine, il s'agit donc d'une
campagne de 60 ans par le grand public, je veux dire nbc,
le New York Times que j'ai mentionné à l'époque
est impliqué dans ce
nous savons par une nouvelle déclassification
que le new york times euh cbs
nbc a été dès le premier jour soutenu la
commission warren parce que,
entre autres raisons, les gens de cbs john
mccloy  la fille de
qui il était à warren il était commissaire au
rapport de warren
john mccoy sa fille
travaillait avec le
président de cbs et donnait des
informations
sur le développement de ce que cbs faisait
à son père mccloy
et il a été interviewé par walter crocker
et c'est  un
tel réseau de pouvoir
que ces gens sont très protégés
et McCoy tombe maladroitement mais il
ne répond clairement pas aux questions
posées par posées par le béton qui
disent directement qu'il n'y avait pas de conflit d'
intérêts et qu'il y avait
un conflit d'intérêts  euh trois des
membres des sept
d'entre nous trois des sept membres de la
commission euh
john sherman cooper hale boggs et
surtout richard russell de géorgie
ont eu des problèmes avec les conclusions
et nous montrons à partir des dossiers classifiés
comment
leur témoignage quoi surtout  leurs
questions ont été
effacées de la réunion de transcription finale,
ils n'apparaissent pas
quand russell l'a découvert deux
ans plus tard, il était furieux
euh bu  il était trop tard, il a parlé, nous avons eu
un appel téléphonique avec lui et
lyndon johnson où ils parlent
de la balle magique
et lui et russell disent qu'il ne le croit tout simplement
pas parce que c'est juste
incroyable non non personne ne tirerait comme
ça personne  pourrait-il n'y a pas de balle comme
celle-ci faite
et johnson lui-même dit que je ne le crois
pas non plus je ne crois pas la même
balle qui a frappé kennedy a frappé connolly
c'est ce qu'il dit
donc je veux dire que vous avez tout cela, nous soulevons
toutes ces choses que nous entendons  en plein
jour sur les
téléphones et on les voit et c'est assez
intéressant
on croyait que la commission warren avait été
achetée par la presse et vendue au
public américain le premier jour
il faut se rendre compte que c'est un
document de 800 pages et qu'il
arrive six mois plus tard  était un 26
volumes
de témoignage spécifique qui n'a même pas été
examiné
car il est venu plus tard, donc le tout a
été vendu le premier jour
car oswald est le seul assassin le seul assassin
ne l'a jamais prouvé nous allons au nous allons et
dans toutes les preuves  ence sur oswald toutes les
preuves originales et nous montrons que c'est
un arbre
qui est des trajectoires d'autopsie des
empreintes digitales de fusil à balle
et surtout l'autopsie était une fraude
et ils ils aucun d'eux ne tient le coup ils
auraient été expulsés du tribunal le premier
jour
c'est une information très importante  cette
preuve originale et c'est à cause de la
déclassification que
nous avons pu enfin aborder ce
qu'ils quoi la
commission euh la commission warren a été
informée
des preuves très importantes euh répondre aux
suggestions des
suggestions d'alan dulles impliqué dans des
assassinats d'
enfants les essais de but à tampa en floride
et
chicago vous savez  que l'expression
conspiration euh
sera utilisée parce que la théorie du complot
euh
comment les élites utilisent cette expression alors
pour délégitimer les preuves
et les papiers réels je veux dire là je veux dire que les gens
ne croiraient pas à l'opération
trombone et mangouste et vous savez
leurs trucs bizarres que nous connaissons maintenant comme
fait,
nous sommes appelés les théoriciens du complot
depuis 1991 et les gens
vous appellent comme ça  c'est facile
c'est un terme de dérogation de la cia
pour discréditer les gens qu'ils ont
inventés dans les années 1950 dans
la guerre psychologique psyops ils ont dit que nous
appellerions ces gens des
théoriciens du complot d'accord
c'est bien mais nous savons par l'histoire
qu'il y a eu tellement de complots
remontant aux romains  les grecs
au delà au delà c'est l'histoire des
conspirations
c'est la nature de l'homme il n'y a pas de raison de
ne pas y croire dans ce cas
euh mais nous on pense qu'on va très loin
pour prouver qu'il y avait au delà d'un
complot c'était un
il y avait un complot pour  tuer et il y
avait un complot pour les dissimuler, ce
qui est plus grand et avec des implications
pour des
millions et des millions peut-être des dizaines de
millions de
vies de personnes, donc nous allons nous fier à
plus d'informations
euh peut-être si joe biden un catholique irlandais
euh permet aux journaux de  être libéré, je
dois
vraiment finir de donner ce catholique, il
aussi
à John Kennedy, c'est vrai et il a
les racines irlandaises, j'imagine qu'il y a de la
sympathie là-bas,
mais t  il n'y a aucun moyen que bain qui est un
guerrier froid de longue date
se heurte à la structure du pouvoir
après kennedy je répète que le
secteur militaire et le
secteur du renseignement étaient intouchables il
est devenu clair que vous ne pouviez
pas entrer dans leur n'a pas coupé leur
kennedy  coupait les bases des bases de défense
et euh dans notre pays et à l'étranger il était en
quelque sorte en train de
ramener des troupes d'afghanistan
j'aimerais voir biden aller plus loin
euh nous avons tellement euh nous avons un budget de mille milliards de
dollars maintenant avec l'armée
essentiellement dans le fait du renseignement
donc c'est un long chemin à parcourir, mais peut-il
toucher
cela vraiment d'une manière essentielle, c'est
ce que faisait Kennedy en renvoyant
la cia et ses deux assistants
euh cabell et bissell vous ne pouvez pas croire
les ondes de choc qu'il a envoyées à travers
washington ici il  est le jeune homme
après truman et eisenhower le jeune
homme 42 33 ans qui
attend commence à changer les choses la
façon dont les choses ont été faites il ne croyait pas
au colonialisme il ne croyait pas au
guerre froide
et il s'éloignait d'eux il avait
été
dégrisé et il avait été éduqué par la baie
des cochons
et surtout par la
crise des missiles cubains il était un homme changé
maintenant quand enfin quand des preuves explosives
en noir et blanc sont produites euh regardez
chez julian
assange selon l'onu torturé ici
le fondateur de wikileaks que va-
t-il se passer à propos de la sortie de ce
documentaire pourquoi êtes-vous en canette
et pourquoi n'est-il pas sur euh tous les
services de streaming aux états-unis pour que
tout le monde puisse le regarder  à partir de la semaine prochaine
écoutez ce film n'a pas été financé en
Amérique nous sommes allés voir les streamers
ils nous ont refusé nous avons été financés depuis l'
angleterre c'était ingénieux une nouvelle société
cinématographique une société cinématographique indépendante
qui a financé ce film maintenant en ce qui
concerne la distribution
nous ne  savoir ce qui va se passer en
amérique nous savons que nous sommes chez khan et
nous nous vendons
très bien parmi les pays européens je
pense qu'une entreprise américaine aurait du
courage devrait avoir le courage  e pour
intensifier et faire cela
mais c'est le climat du pays à
ce stade après 2001
et l'approche conservatrice croissante
du gouvernement de
la peur la peur du déclin
euh une peur d'attaque euh sur nos
valeurs tout cela aveugle l'amérique
effrayant l'américain  euh le gouvernement dans la
censure sur youtube la
censure et la censure facebook d'un
ex-président
pendant deux ans suspendu de twitter
c'est stupéfiant euh je pense que tu vas
et puis ils sont coupés rt
dans une certaine mesure ils font
pression  rg dans tous les pays du
monde, comme vous le
savez peut-être, et en Amérique du Sud, même
partout, le pays très puissant des États-Unis,
mais
je ne crois pas qu'ils
pourront fermer cette
actualité, nous allons être libérés
euh et  nous en angleterre ça va être
publié par altitude au royaume
-uni et l'irlande sera la société qui le
libère
oliver stone merci bien merci
ashley
vous